I'm Bill McFarlane and I'm the Scout Master with Troop 8 in Kittsville, Massachusetts.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast, sponsored by Packers Like Me.
And now to you, Scout Master.
Now, camping can be full of misery and discomfort and challenges and rain and mud, and you know all of those things.
but, no matter what, it's all over much too soon, don't you think?
Hey, this is podcast number 267.. Hey,
Hey, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Well, I hope you enjoyed the last three podcasts about the Scouting Source Code
And I've saved up a number of email questions for this week's podcast. but I'm getting a little ahead of myself.
Let's take a look at the mailbag first.
Shane Lehman. Shane Lehman is a troop scouter with the 63rd Ottawa Scout Troop in Ottawa, Ontario, Canada,
And he wrote in to say this: last weekend I completed my outdoor skill training and you might be happy to know that at two of the training stands at the event,
your PDF material was used as training material. Well, how about that? huh,
I remarked. hey, I know this guy. You should follow his blog and podcast.
So this is evidence that you're making an impact up above the 49th parallel.
Well, Shane, thanks so much for letting me know and for supporting the blog and podcast. I really do appreciate it
And it's always heartening, humbling and honoring to know that people actually find all of this stuff useful
And it actually appears out there in the real world. So I appreciate you being in touch.
Linda Lansford is with Scout Troop 17 in Nashville, Tennessee,
And she said: thank you so much for posting the video about autism and scouting and one boy's personal journey.
And if you didn't see that, that was a video that I posted last week that I found on YouTube,
just kind of one of those serendipitous things that every once in a while you run across,
And it's a wonderful story about one scout's experience in scouting and how the folks that were involved supported him
and helped him through some challenges with autism And it's really, really great.
But anyway, Linda went on to say: one minute in, I was literally in tears.
I identified with Chase's mother- and Chase was the name of the scout in the video-
So much that her words could be mine. I'm the mother of a 12-year-old scout with Asperger's.
When we first joined Troop 17 in Nashville it was hard for me to step back
and let my son fully experience scouting. I'm so used to managing his world for him.
The Troop leader took the time to reassure me, telling me that my son was not the first autistic scout he'd worked with
and that everything would be okay. And it's so much more than okay. It's amazing.
The Troop is teaching him to be self-sufficient and teaching me to have faith, trust and let go.
We're starting our third year with Troop 17, and I have a very different child.
Each time he goes away to summer or winter camp he comes home with a little more confident,
a little more mature, a little farther down the road to becoming an amazing young man.
Thank you so much, Linda, for getting in touch,
And that is a story that we are increasingly hearing about autistic children being able to draw a lot from their scouting experience.
It seems almost as though that scouting was designed to address some of the challenges that they come up with,
and it's just a wonderful thing to hear that it does so.
And I know- I know from personal experience- it's very, very challenging the first time you go through this
as a scouter and you learn a lot. but, man, what an enriching experience for you as a scouter,
as well as for the scout and their family too.
So thank you once again, Linda, for being in touch.
I want to tell you that I was very honored to spend this past weekend in the company
and a number of scouts from the Baden Powell Service Association, the BPSA.
What wonderful folks. I've got a lot of material to cover in this podcast,
so I'll save that whole story for another time perhaps.
I was very heartened to meet these wonderful people in the BPSA
and I got to become a rover scout- How about that?
Yes, R-O-V-E-R rover,
And, like I said, we have a lot to do today, so I'll have to save that story for another time,
but it's a pretty good one.
Now, from time to time during the week, usually on weekday mornings,
we'll turn the live chat on over at scoutmastercgcom.
Check in, see if we're on and watch the Facebook and Twitter feeds,
because we'll announce when we're going to be live
And you know, come on, sign in, join in.
We have some very serious and meaningful discussions
and we have some that aren't so much.
What it is is just a virtual campfire session with some of your scouting buddies.
So, in addition to a growing number of frequent fliers who check in on the chat regularly,
we also got to hear from Paige Lawson, who's a roundtable commissioner in Kansas City, Missouri,
and Jim Bresinger, who's a cubmaster from Midlothian Illinois, this past week,
And I know there were a couple of other people that signed on for their first time
and I was just, but I was as busy as a one-armed paper hanger a couple mornings this week
and I missed getting names and locations and things. but welcome to the chat
And do come in and check us out.
Once again, I'll typically announce it on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed
and you can always get in touch with me via email at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
Hey, before we go any further, let me take the time to ask you a favor, because I need your help.
You know this whole thing- this crazy blog and podcast thing- started back in 2005..
I had no plan. I had no idea what this would grow into, but now I hear from a lot of folks every week
and this is where I devote my time and it's really heartening to know that people find this useful.
So what I'm asking in return is that you support the podcast and the blog by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
It's very, very simple: Go to scoutmastercgcom, click the support link at the top of the page
and you'll find a number of options on making a voluntary one-time kind of subscription payment to keep things up and running.
So let me take a moment to personally thank Brad Watts, Bill Blankowski and Bill McFarland,
who have become backers since our last podcast.
Once again, go to scoutmastercgcom, become a backer this week
and I'll make sure to thank you during our next podcast.
Well, the remainder of this podcast is catching up on email questions and answers
and that will indeed stretch out for a while and take up the rest of this podcast.
So let's get started. shall we
Find me a letter? send it my name,
Email. that is, folks. And here's an answer to one of your emails.
So the first email- I'm going to hold all of the identifying characteristics of it in confidence,
But this came from the scoutmaster of a newer troop and he said:
we are having a discussion about the cooking requirement for tenderfoot
and we're wondering exactly how we should judge that.
Does helping get lunch ready by, you know, just kind of helping them around with the condiments
and getting the bread out and stuff like that to make sandwiches, Is that cooking?
And if a scout is just kind of assisting with another person with the cooking,
is that really cooking And we're having a tough time deciding exactly
how a scout's fulfilled that requirement.
Well, I think it's important- not just on this particular tenderfoot requirement, right,
But for any of the requirements that we use- is to step back a little bit
and read the requirement carefully and you know what.
Once you do it becomes pretty clear and you don't have to have a big discussion about how to do it.
It's right there.
This particular tenderfoot requirement says, quote:
on the camp out: assist in preparing and cooking one of your patrol's meals.
Pretty simple sentence, right.
And if you read that and then you go off and you start having a big broad discussion about it,
you can get pretty far afield and kind of talk yourself into a corner
where you can't find an answer.
But if you just look at the requirement and kind of break it down, it's pretty simple.
So the first three words in the requirement are on the camp out, right.
So that means on a camp out.
It's very, very simple, not at home or anywhere else.
So we've got that right:
Assist, preparing and cooking.
So on the camp out, assist preparing and cooking.
Preparing and cooking are obviously two different things,
Otherwise we wouldn't need two words there.
So on the camp out, assist preparing and cooking one of your patrol's meals?
Okay, so it's not just any meal,
It's not just something for yourself,
It's one of your patrol's meals.
So that wouldn't be a meal fixed by an adult or directed by one,
It's your patrol, because you know adults have nothing to do with what happens when a patrol cooks.
So the test for that particular requirement would be to say:
number one: was it on a camp out?
Yes,
Did the scout assist with both preparing and cooking,
Which I guess you know? that could be a point of contention with a lot of people.
but hey, you know we're not building a nuclear power plant.
Okay,
We're trying to do something simple and fun with scouts.
And if you come across something like this in a requirement that you're having a tough time trying to define,
don't create a rule for it.
Ask the scout-
So what do you think cooking is?
And have that discussion.
And hey, the scout may say, you know what,
I really didn't, don't think I cooked anything,
And say, okay, well then let's wait until you've actually done that,
Or they may have a very good argument for why they feel that they cooked something.
But ask them,
Get them into the conversation,
Don't make it a totally adult decision.
Make it something that the scout is participating in.
And then the final question in this requirement to me is: hey, who was the meal for?
Was it for your patrol?
And if it wasn't, well, does it qualify or not?
Probably not, right,
It's very, very specific about those particular points.
So adults are not around when patrols cook their meals, necessarily.
So the person who's going to sign this requirement off, to my mind at least,
is going to be the one who worked directly with the scout,
And that would likely be the patrol leader, correct?
So I'd expect the patrol leader knows the difference between preparing and cooking
and let him figure out if the scout passed the requirement.
And once again, these kinds of discussions are the ones that we want to be having with scouts.
It may not sound right to you that I am suggesting that a patrol leader can sign off a requirement,
But hey, they absolutely can.
And usually when I suggest that that's one way of doing things,
people get concerned that patrol leaders are just going to skip things over and things like that.
Well, no, that doesn't necessarily follow,
especially if you are working along and mentoring patrol leaders to understand requirements
and be able to sign them off effectively right.
So what I read out was just the first part of that tenderfoot requirement.
There's another part to it.
It says: tell why it's important for each patrol member to share in meal preparation
and clean up and explain the importance of eating together.
And what I want to point out about that that I feel is very important
is the active verb in that particular sentence: tell.
Tell means telling, not writing,
And the patrol leader, once again, can ask the scout some questions
and sign off that part of the requirement too.
Now I kind of paraphrased the email that I got
because I wanted to preserve the sender's anonymity,
but they discussed in there that the parents of the particular scout
in question were kind of getting themselves involved with this.
Well, I want to tell you that mother and father have absolutely nothing at all
to do with any of this.
This is something that their scout is doing.
So they're not allowed on a soccer field when the game is on
and they aren't allowed in a patrol campsite
when scouts are working together as a patrol.
Parents don't make the referees call at a soccer game or keep score.
They're spectators,
And that's the same thing when scouts are camping,
You can be a spectator,
You can watch from an appropriate distance,
but you may not tell the referee or the scorekeeper.
So you know, in my little allegory here
that would be the scouter or the patrol leader-
How to do their job.
You can be there and you can observe,
That's fine.
So after I answered the initial email that I got,
I got this reply.
So the parents are saying that the way they read the requirement
is that the boy assistant preparing and assistant cooking.
they feel that the actual cooking is not required.
Well, you know what.
Parents are often trying to be helpful
and they're trying to advocate for their child
and that's fine
And I understand their concerns.
but there's a judgment call involved here
and that's a call for the scouter to make
and not for parents to make.
And I would very politely tell them.
you know I understand your concerns
and please understand that I am thoroughly invested
in making sure that your child is treated fairly.
But in this part of the scouting process,
this is really my call and my call is going to stand.
It's not set a precedent where we're going to argue
over every single little thing.
Let's just have fun and be in scouts
and do these things.
And I ask you to give me the benefit of a doubt here,
And I typically advise scouts that if they acquiesce-
just because there's a lot of parental pressure-
to something that they feel is unreasonable
And the way that the parents are putting this-
cooking not being actual cooking,
you know, I think that's a good example
of being unreasonable.
If you acquiesce to something like that,
they're going to question and complain
every single thing. from now on,
Let's make it clear from the get go
Who will be doing the interpreting and deciding.
Okay,
Parents' input is always important.
We always want to listen to their concerns,
But we also want to understand
the way that the process works.
I heard from Mason Turner and he said
I want to jump right in and ask:
how do I get troops to give me den chiefs
for my Cub Scout pack?
We don't have any kind of great relationship
with our neighboring troops,
So how can we initiate those relationships?
Do I offer them a presentation on the new Cub program
or something like that?
Do you have any ideas for me?
Well, this is kind of frustrating, Mason.
I wish your pack was down the road from us.
I've also had a lot of challenges
from the troop side of the question
in forming relationships with Cub packs
And I feel kind of like. sometimes
we go to the dance and we ask them to dance
and they just keep turning us down.
What a sad, sad allegory that one is.
But you know what, Mason?
Here's what I suggest:
Get on the phone with the scout masters
in the troops around you
and ask them if they're willing to help you out,
that you'd like to get some scouts to serve as den chiefs.
Put the ball in their court by saying something: like
you know, we'd really like to get better connected with the troop
and we'd like to have den chiefs involved with us
on a regular basis.
And the first scout master who responds
with an actual plan of action
is probably the one that you're going to end up working with
Now. I asked to visit their next troop meeting
and see what the general vibe is
and talk to a couple of scouts
And if it seems like a pretty good bunch,
move on forward.
My bet is that if you were to call five scout masters,
at least one is going to get back to you
with a plan of action,
And the ones who are put off
or pass you off to somebody else
I wouldn't really be bothered with.
But often getting that connection
is really as simple as that.
Now the next email.
I'm going to leave the sender's name anonymous
And the reason for that will become apparent
as we go through it.
It's time to move to a new troop.
We've visited our new troop
and I've talked with the scout master.
What's the best procedure for informing
our current troop that we plan to move?
Do I write a letter to the troop committee
chairman or the scout master?
Is there a typical way that this is handled?
So if you've been listening or reading for a while,
you will have heard email questions
where issues arise
where there's basic disagreement
with the way things are going in one scout troop,
And I typically advise the parent
or the scouter, if things just aren't
working for them in one troop, that,
hey, it's a good idea to look at others
and make a decision
And to find one that more closely resembles
what you hope to have for your child
or your experience as a scouter.
And then just change troops
And I don't think this has to be a big deal at all
And I think good starting place
is the scout himself.
Talk about making the change with them,
Ask them how they want to handle it,
And they may be in a position
where they would want to do something
like go and talk to the scout master
or something like that or not.
I would allow them to define exactly
how they were going to handle the move,
within reason of course,
And I get the idea of sending a letter
or something like that.
But a letter also has a way of backfiring on you,
because sometimes these changes
are not totally amicable
And sometimes they're caused
by pretty sharp disagreements
or difficulties,
And so a letter or an email about it
may backfire on you,
because any letter or email
is going to get the fine tooth comb treatment,
And if it's a sharp disagreement
or a conflict of some kind,
it's very unlikely that the troop
that you're leaving is going to read that
and say, ooh hey, we were wrong all along.
They're more likely to brand you as a troublemaker
and let everybody else in scouting know
exactly the way that they think of it.
Now isn't that unfortunate, but it happens
In most situations that I hear about.
I would roughly suggest
shake hands and say
thank you very much,
We've enjoyed our time here,
but we're going to be changing troops,
So this will be our last time here
and then we'll be doing
scouting over in the other troop across town
or whatever.
If you're asked to explain-
well, you can explain or not-
I would say maybe don't.
I would just keep the whole thing
on as high a plane
and make it as amicable as possible,
because there is
plenty of needless drama
in scouting
and in life in general,
and your son's interest
is the most important interest here.
So let's make the elements of this change
that you can control,
which is your attitude
and the way that you're going to do it,
as drama-free as possible.
Robert got in touch with me with this question.
I wanted to get your thoughts on the policy manual
I was planning on creating
that explained our troop rules and traditions
and note the origin of each
in scouting literature.
I'm a fairly new scout master
and I think having this defined
for everyone would be helpful.
What do you think? Does this seem reasonable?
I know that you don't recommend
writing policy manuals.
Well, Robert, I think writing
things out like this
may be useful for you
to kind of think your way through things,
but I would suggest that it will
only be marginally useful
for parents in the committee
and it's not really
going to be very useful for your scouts.
Now, is this a reasonable idea?
Well, of course it makes perfect sense, right,
That you would have this document
that kind of helps define things for everybody.
But is it really a great idea?
Not to my lights,
and I want to explain why.
I know how strong the desire is
to explain everything to our scouts,
but my normal advice
is to resist the temptation
to explain
and participate
in the cooperative process
where scouts
discover these things for themselves.
Few if any
of the scouts that I have worked with
read manuals,
job descriptions,
policies, procedures,
and few adults do that
either.
They usually go off of what they are told
and what they are used to have happening,
And I think we could ask anyone
on the end of any customer
service line
whether or not people actually read
directions and manuals,
and we'd find out that for the most part,
no, they don't.
That's why we have customer service lines, right.
The other aspect of this is,
as soon as you create a list of rules
or procedures or policies,
you're really kind of limiting yourself
to the rules and procedures
and policies that you've written.
If you give a scout a printed copy
of his job description,
that might be helpful
to what's on that piece of paper.
So what I typically suggest
is that process that I referred to earlier,
which is explaining
things as they come along
by asking questions.
So take something really really simple:
What does an assistant patrol leader do?
So you get to a meeting
and the scouts come to you
and say our patrol leader isn't here.
So you ask the question:
who becomes your patrol leader
if your patrol leader is absent?
and they look at you and they say,
ooh, I don't know.
They say so, who do you think
that person ought to be?
And they are staring at you
with blank faces saying,
what do you mean?
I guess we could pick somebody.
Well, do you guys have an assistant patrol leader?
Oh,
yeah.
So have you checked
in the scout handbook?
who takes over when the patrol leader's not here?
No,
Maybe there would be something in there about that.
So you get the idea:
Instead of answering that question with a declarative statement
or having it instituted in a piece of literature
that you created somewhere,
well, they have a scout handbook that explains all of this-
It's already written-
and getting them into the idea of taking a look
and answering their questions themselves,
you get them in a process
that begins to self-replicate
and really leverages
that process of discovery
that you want to see happen in scouts.
So when it gets down to things like:
well, what are our rules of conduction?
We have some rules of conduct.
How will these scouts know how to behave
if we don't have rules of conduct?
Well, they have the scout oath and law.
That's their rules of conduct.
You really don't need to write anything else.
You have the scout oath and law.
It's already there.
The scout handbook and the senior patrol leader's handbook
explain everything anybody needs to know
about the mechanics
and you really don't have to rewrite those.
If you want scouts to learn
how to do much of anything or how things work,
you have to let them actually do them
in real time
and then you talk about what they did
and you can introduce all kinds of ideas
this way and you can ask all kinds of questions
And rather than
setting yourself up as the authority,
they have a broader authority to go to.
they have a handbook to go to,
they have places where they can find information
and you become their partner in discovery
rather than being the source of everything.
Now I heard back from Robert and he said:
thanks for your reply.
I'm still a little unclear.
It says specifically in the scout master handbook
that rank and age requirements to be senior
patrol leader are determined by each troop,
as is the schedule of elections.
So my troop has generally said
that the senior patrol leader
needs to be at least life rank
and the election schedule is after summer camp
and right after winter camp.
So where do we record the election schedule
and the troop rules for
senior patrol leader qualifications?
Do we just keep this as an
unwritten rule, kind of
tribal knowledge?
And my reply was:
that's an excellent question.
I understand I'm kind of pushing you around a little bit here,
but play my little game for a moment.
I'm not trying to consciously
frustrate you, even though it might seem that way.
Let me answer
your questions with more questions.
Why do you need an election schedule
And what happens when you need to have
an election outside that schedule?
What happens when a scout who hasn't
reached life but would make an excellent senior
patrol leader ask you why you have
such a requirement?
What happens if you have no life scouts interested
in being the senior patrol leader?
What happens if you have a scout who isn't
interested in advancement at all
and wants to be the senior patrol leader?
So you can see what I'm saying
In those situations if you've already
instituted a set of rules
or a policy manual.
there's a lot of unintended consequences
out of that because you've kind of
written yourself into a corner.
What I like to see better is that
when stuff happens,
the patrol leader's counsel sits down
and discusses their way through it.
If you create a bunch of rules or
qualifications, you kind of limit the
number of possible resolutions
to the situation at hand.
A policy manual like this, outside of
the couple of million of policies,
tends to fence you
and your youth leadership in,
And by rewriting what's already
written you're really in danger
of significantly skewing and distorting
what really ought to be happening.
This is all a little unsettling,
I understand, But if you
understand what I'm trying to say,
99.99% of everything
that you need in writing
to describe what you do
in playing the game of scouting
is already in writing.
You don't need to recreate it.
I heard back from Robert who said:
I think I understand, although I'm not sure I agree.
it seems to me that unwritten rules
are more pervasive and harder to change
or even recognize than they are
if they're written down. The more organic,
informal approach that you describe
may be something that I have to grow into.
Who knows, maybe my policy
and procedure manual will be
really, really short, Or maybe I'll get
through writing it and realize it's mostly worthless
and just throw it away. Well, Robert,
now we're getting to the point where we're
in agreement. okay, I think
writing the manual is a great exercise for you
yourself and maybe for the other adults
who are involved with you, Because it will help
you think your way through things. You'll go
to the scouting resources, you'll find these things,
and then you'll find that, hey, what we're doing
basically is recreating something
that already exists, so we really don't need it.
but now we know where to find all this
information. And I'm not really
suggesting any kind of unwritten rules
or tribal knowledge. What I'm
saying is is that everything you need
is already written. You don't
have to recreate it in your own
specific manual, That doing
that really has a lot of unintended
consequences, And that
if you go to the resources
that already contain all the information
anybody needs and you make a habit
of that with your scouts and with
your adults, well, you're going to be in a
lot less danger of following
habits or traditions that
don't reflect what you actually
want to be doing. So it's not really a matter of
unwritten rules and traditions
taking over, It's
making sure that you're going to the
resources that are already there and
defining what you do according to what
you find in them. Scott Peterson
is the scout master of Troop 626
in Spring, Texas,
and he says: I've been a scout master
for three years. I'm just starting to
realize how really little I know
about scouting and I'm anxious to learn more.
I found your site a few months ago
and I can't thank you enough for sharing your
experience with us. How do you
suggest scout leaders should be addressed
by scouts? I was watching some
of the videos you made at summer camp last
summer and you walked up to talk with your senior
patrol leader and he said: hello, Clark,
and that kind of surprised me. Maybe
I'm a little fashion, because I always
referred to adults- teachers, parents,
friends etc. as Mr or Mrs
and my coaches- rather than Mr
or Mrs I would use the word coach
and then their name- and I'm curious to hear what
you think about this. Well, so far as
I can tell Scott, the literature I've
looked at is pretty silent on this.
I can tell you just from my
own experience. I was a very young scout
master at the age of 24, and
my scouts called me by my first name
at that time because it
just seemed to be the comfortable thing to do
and it stuck for the next 30
years. I think another part of this is I
worked on camp staff for about 12 years
and everyone called me by my first
name, as they did with our previous camp
director who was much older than me and who had
been there for 29 years. First names-
I don't think they're necessarily
improper. calling people Mr and Mrs,
I don't think that's improper. I guess
it's just whatever everyone feels comfortable
with doing. My personal answer to the
question is: I don't really care what manner of address
scouts use. as far as I'm concerned,
I am not a particularly important
person or in a position of
grandiosity that I think needs a title.
I mean, I'm in a position of service
and provisional authority when
needed. Whatever form of address
works for them works for me. in other words,
I really value the idea that
I'm on the same level as my scouts.
in many ways I like being
called by my first name. I don't
have to demand respect or be placed on a
pedestal and what they call being
never really affected things one way
or the other. And in our
sixth and final email in this
podcast, I got this
question recently. our
committee was urging the patrol leaders
council to plan a supertrip
for spring. that would be something
like we have done in the past, which is
basically a road trip that features visits
to historic sites and museums and the
scouts may be camping out, but you know
we're eating in restaurants and going on tours.
to me these seem like school or family
trips, not scouting trips.
I'd rather go backpacking or
canoeing or something like that involving
the outdoors, rather than do something
like this. Am I off base?
I mean, do I have a leg to stand
on if I go to the committee and ask them to stop
promoting this type of trip? well, that's
an excellent question, because the supertrip
you describe is one activity.
it's certainly not prohibited
by any procedures or policies
that I could find. I think this is
looking at possible activities
and deciding whether or not they are
in the spirit of scouting and whether or not
they're going to achieve the aims of
scouting. So I have
a long established
rule of thumb, which is kind of a little
three-point test, that I apply to
activities. If the activities pass
all three of these questions,
we can safely say that they are
optimal scouting
activities that will achieve the aims of scouting
okay. so the first question I would ask
is: does the activity achieve
the aims of scouting? does it result in
opportunities for personal growth?
now, a lot of activities
would definitely do that, even the one you
describe. I can see how
you could justify it in that it
would advance the aims of scouting,
of personal growth, physically, mentally
and spiritually. in all of that okay.
but now let's go to question number two:
does the activity encourage the development
and the strengthening of the patrol system?
now we're getting down into
a couple of other things that
may suggest there would be better
activities than the supertrip you describe.
sure, patrols could divide up and go on the
tours and eat in restaurants that way
and things like that, and that
would help support and develop the patrol system.
but is that really the optimum
kind of environment for that, or
is there a better one? and my third
test is asking whether the
activity is a preplanned kind
of canned event that is
presented to the scouts,
or is it something that they actually
make happen for themselves? and I think
this is where you kind of have to cross
the supertrip off the list, at least
in my estimation. this is something
that where they go through an evolution
that's pretty much planned for them
and it's not really something that they're making
happen for themselves. but, Clark, you say
what if they plan the outing? you know
what if they planned what museum they were going to
go to and everything like that? once again,
hey, folks, these are rules of thumb.
okay, what's optimal
for us to participate in a scouts
and what's maybe not the
best thing in the world for us to do
so? simply comparing the two alternatives
that you've posed here- the supertrip,
museums, staying in hotels
or campsites, eating in
restaurants, touring museums and things like that-
is it a terrible thing for scouts
to do? no, absolutely not.
are there better things that scouts could be doing
that would maybe be
more optimal towards achieving our aims?
yeah, in my personal opinion.
yeah, I think so. I think camping or canoeing
or backpacking or something in the wilds,
where they're encountering
a number of challenges
along the way, where they're,
where they're placed in
an unfamiliar environment, that
where they have to function well
as a patrol in order to get
through the activity and have fun
and be comfortable with it. my personal
take would be that camping or backpacking
or canoeing, hey, that would be much better.
so maybe, I hope-
I hope I'm not muddying the water,
but you know, if you were asking me to choose
between the supertrip kind of road
tour or doing something in the woods,
I'll take the woods every time,
but that's not to say that the tour
is totally useless in and of itself.
there were an improper thing
for scouts to do.
I just have my personal preferences
that I think huge closer
to the line of playing the game of
scouting. well, that was a lot of email
questions. I hope you found my answers
useful. if you have
a question and you'd like to get in touch,
it's very easy to do and I'm going to tell you
how to do just that in just a moment.
music.
hey, thanks for listening to this
267th edition
of the scout master podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
go to the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and you can sign up to an email subscription
that will send every update to the blog
to your email inbox.
you can join the other mobile scouts
or have the scout master cg app on their mobile devices,
and the app is available both
on the google play and the itunes app store.
you can experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
there's 8900 folks who like
scout master blog. on facebook,
there's 1200 tweeters that tweet along
with us. on twitter,
there are 2000 pinners who pin
his pictures. we profit publicly
on pinterest. you can watch scout master cg
on youtube and you can
join the 500 odd folks who form
the exclusive scout master cg circle
on google plus. what's that you say?
you can't face facebook. twitter
makes you bitter. you've no interest in pinterest.
you don't put the? u in youtube
and you're a minus when it comes to google plus.
that's okay, bunkie,
just zoom into the late 90s
and fire off an email. yep,
you can email me. clark green
comments and questions
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
c-l-a-r-k-e
at scoutmastercgcom.
the scout master blog
and the scout master podcast do not have
the sponsorship or endorsement
of any scouting organization.
they are solely a product of my own ramblings
and prognostications. it's
just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scouters everywhere
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
let's hear from our founder, sir robert biden.
sir robert,
good luck to you and good camping,
why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.